donc madame la ministre l'acce rhône
saône moselle était déjà le premier axe
nord sud de l'europe à l'époque romaine
aujourd'hui tutti dysfonctionne par une
série de non décision de mauvaises
décisions et le pire est pour demain
la route de la soie arrive au port de
rotterdam se prolonge par chemin de fer
à bettembourg puis se diffuse au sud par
notre réseau routier et autoroutier nous
engorgeant nous polluants le
gouvernement français en répercuter le
coût sur les usagers français après
avoir renoncé à faire payer le transit
international par l'écotaxe poids lourds
alors qu'elle existe chez nos voisins
européens
la première mauvaise décision et l
abandon de cette taxe qui aurait
pourtant deux paires de permis de faire
payer le transit international qui ces
infractions turquie luz en mettant en
oeuvre le principe du pollueur payeur
ce fiasco s'est soldée par le versement
d'un milliard d'euros à ecomouv en
indemnités un manque à gagner d'un
milliard d'euros chaque année pour
financer nos infrastructures et la perte
de centaines d'emplois promis à metz en
compensation des restructurations
militaires faute d'écotaxe ce sont les
lorrains dont les cent mille
travailleurs frontaliers qui devrait
payer un péage sur l'a 31 bis pour
rejoindre le luxembourg comme vous
l'avez décidé le 24 septembre jusqu'à 6
euros 36 par pers par automobiliste
faute des quotas que ce sont aussi tous
les automobilistes français qui sont
taxés et sans alternative
acculés ils se révoltent en mettant leur
gilet jaune à leur première question
pourquoi ne mettez vous pas en place
cette écotaxe deuxièmement vous avait
annoncé le 5 juillet dernier ici
l'abandon par le gouvernement du projet
de liaison fluviale saône-moselle
m'expliquant que son coût était
insoutenable pour la france mais il
s'agit d'un projet européen alors
deuxième question allez-vous porter et
défendre ce projet au niveau pertinent
le rang cerise sur le gâteau nous avons
appris le 26 septembre dernier la
suppression de la liaison ferroviaire
mais smith pour rallier le sud de la
france des lorrains doivent passer par
trois bourgs ou par paris ça va
pénaliser les nombreux voyageurs hausse
du prix des billets qu'on
en pratique et absurdités sur le plan
écologique
alors troisième question allez-vous
rétablir la liaison ferroviaire directe
mais ce nice avec une question 3 bis
allez-vous ranfaing réduire
l'embouteillage ferroviaire à lyon qui
empêche le développement de l'autoroute
ferroviaire
bettembourg perpignan perpignan merci la
parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre chargé des transports
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur grosdidier
avant toute chose concernant l'éco taxe
je souhaiterais affirmer ici que le
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
restaurer ce système mais vous le savez
nous sommes confrontés à plusieurs défis
l'état de nos réseaux de transport s'est
fortement dégradée depuis de trop
nombreuses années
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a décidé
d'inscrire dans la loi mobilité une
programmation des infrastructures
sincère qui prévoit une augmentation de
40% des investissements dans le système
de transport pour les cinq prochaines
années en 2019 cette augmentation des
investissements a été réalisée par
redéploiement au sein du budget de
l'état il faudra une ressource nouvelle
et durable à hauteur de 500 millions
d'euros à partir de 2020 concernant le
secteur nord de l'a 31 bis la
réalisation d'un contournement de
thionville en tracé neuf et nécessaire
un débat public sur les différentes
options de tracés vient d'être lancé
puis une décision ministérielle fixera
les conditions de réalisation documents
notamment au sujet de la mise en place
d'un péage qui permettra de financer et
de réaliser des travaux dans un délai
raisonnable je sais la contrainte
financière que représente ce pays
ce péage pour les usagers de l'a 31 mais
il est indispensable pour répondre
rapidement aux difficultés connues dans
le secteur concernant le projet
saône-rhin saône-moselle que vous
appelez de vos voeux
il s'agit d'un projet de 350 km de voies
navigables
avec un coût de l'ordre de 15 milliards
d'euros malgré l'impact économique de ce
projet sur la région le coût de cette
infrastructure apparaît aujourd'hui hors
de portée des financements envisageable
même en intégrant le soutien de l'union
européenne ne peut donc malheureusement
pas constituer une réponse avant un
horizon de long terme
enfin concernant la liaison tgv mais
snif la gare de lyon part dieu connaît
précisément des travaux 1
pourtant jusqu'en 2023 et un débat aura
lieu courant 2010 9 sur le noeud
ferroviaire lyonnais
mais jusqu'en 2023 donc ces travaux
limite la capacité d'accueil entraînant
des modifications de desserte pour
compenser cette situation sncf mobilité
a proposé un départ depuis nancy reliant
strasbourg à marseille et nice le
prolongement de la liaison tgv
montpellier strasbourg jusqu'à metz pour
renforcer le lien avec l'arc
méditerranéen
la sncf a rencontré des élus pour leur
présenter ses propositions en lien avec
la région grand est
par ailleurs un groupe de travail se
réunira autour des sujets de la desserte
ferroviaire pour aborder en amont les
évolutions de la desserte tgv et ter
enfin je précise que la loi pour un
nouveau pacte ferroviaire impose la
création de comités de desserte au sein
desquelles les élus seront représentés